hello everyone
today i'm going to talk about my recent
work with
srinivasanarunachalam and this is about
memoryless communication complexity
so before i begin explaining memoryless
communication complexity
let us quickly recap what the standard
communication complexity is
standard communication complexity was
introduced by
yao in 1979
and uh it looks like this uh here we
have two players
alice and bob and they receive uh their
private inputs
x and y which are n bit string n bit
strings
each and using that they want to jointly
compute a function
f of x y it's a it's a binary
valued function and they're interested
in knowing only the only the function
value
now obviously in order to compute this
compute the function value
they need to communicate so so they
communicate back and forth
by sending bits by sending one bit
one bit at a time and here we assume
that the players are not
limited by any computational time or
memory
in other words they can compute locally
they can compute any functions they like
and they can also remember all the
message transcript that they have
received
or sent previously now
a cost of any communication complexity
protocol
is the total number of bits exchanged
between alice and bob
for the worst possible input
so um we want to optimize on the
on the number of bits a bit sent for
computing any function
so we we defined uh deterministic
communication complexity
uh to be the minimum over all all the
protocols computing the function so it
is
it is denoted by d of f and it is
the cost of best deterministic protocol
computing
computing the function f
people also consider another setting of
communication complexity
which is a one-way communication
complexity here
um everything is same except the fact
that now
only alice is allowed to send messages
to bob
um so so here the cost of any one-way
communication complexity protocol
is the total number of bits sent from
alice to bob
and after receiving all the bits from
from alice
bob computes the function value which is
either 0 or 1.
now we ask this question what if the
players
have no memory in between the rounds
now let me explain what i mean by that
um
we we say that at every round so we want
that
alice computes the next message to send
um so this is this is going to be solely
based on
her input x and the message she has
received from bob in the in the in in
this round
and similarly for bob so bob is going to
compute any message that bob wants to
send in any round
that will would be based solely on his
input y and the message received in this
current round
so let me uh let me further elaborate
with this
with this pictorial representation here
we again have alice and bob
and they have their input x and y
and since they don't have any memory and
they don't even have memory to remember
in which round
uh they're currently they're currently
in
so alice begins and um
in using her input x alice choose
uh chooses a function f of x which c
initially applies on all zero string and
she computes the first message to send
which is
m i 1 m a m a 1.
now bob receives the message m a 1 and
based on his input y chooses
a function f y and
he maps m a i to another message mbi
and sends it to alice and then forgets
about focus about it
and similarly this this keeps on going
and obviously at some point we need to
stop
so uh we denote it by saying that if
ever any player receives a message which
looks like
something like this where it is all
zeros except the last bit is b
then the output b um now
any any protocol computes a function
this way if it if it computes f of x
y for all possible x and y now
it is um um it is it is easy to see that
via a counting argument um that if we
um if we have uh uh
this message to be only a single bit
then it it doesn't suffice to compute
all possible
all possible functions so here we need
to have this message to
to have like length more than one
for computing any non-trivial functions
so so we define the cost of computing
such function in this model
is the size of the largest message
communicated between alice and bob
in any round of the protocol so it is it
is really the
bottleneck size of of the message that
they need to send back and forth
um so so let me um let let me
uh tell a story which fits fits this
model really well
so intuitively it is basically sending a
rewritable message register that that
they can send back and forth
to to compute the function f on all
possible inputs
um so so so we have these two players
alice and bob
and they have their private input so
they remember their private inputs and
with that they want to solve a mystery
um which is basically computing f of x y
now um so so as the story goes they
cannot remember things for too long so
when they when they go to bed they wake
up the next day and they cannot remember
anything from the from the previous day
to make the matter worse they are also
separated by space so they are on two
stranded islands
and it takes few days to send message
from
one um one player to the other
and with that they want to solve a
mystery so they decided to use um
a postal service and they decided to
uh write notes and send back and forth
so with so
they can basically uh sends notes using
um
use using this postal service but
obviously they want to optimize on the
size of the envelope so they want to buy
the
by the smaller envelope possible in
order to accomplish this task
and that is exactly this uh memoryless
model
and we want to optimize on the on the
message register
now um we can also have variance of
memoryless communication complexity
model so note that we we are still
computing the same function
distributed function but we can have
this table
where we can say that the memoryless
model
is where neither alice nor above
have um any any memory we denote it by
nm of f which is by
which is abbreviation of no memory and
this is the complexity of computing any
functions in the know
in the memoryless model but then we can
also have
a model which is memory no memory where
one player has memory
and the second player doesn't have any
memory so we denote it by m of f which
is memory no memory model
and it actually turns out that any
functions
in this model can be computed with at
most login
login size message and the reason is
that here you
the player with the memory can just send
the index to the
it's actually login plus one so the
player um can can just send an index
to the um to the other player and then
the other player
can just reply so the player can send
eye on the other player
bob for instance can reply with y i and
and that way
alice would retrieve bob's whole input
the third variant is where it's a memory
memory model where alice and bob both
have memory
and then this becomes the standard
communication complexity protocol so
here
it's denoted by by d of f but note that
we can also have one way variant of all
this
different variants so we can have
one-way
communication uh complexity but in the
memoryless settings so alice and bob do
not have memory and furthermore
communication only goes from alice to
bomb we denote it by
nm superscript right arrow of f
and it turns out to be standard one-way
communication complexity because
uh it it just since since neither has
memory it just makes sense to send just
one message just in in one shot
and then we can also have uh memory no
memory in the one way setting
and we denote it by m superscript right
arrow f
and um this is exactly this is
exactly a model which was uh actually
studied in 2014 by
papa constantinew and um and and others
and um um yeah
so so we can have all such different
variants
um in the uh by by choosing like how
whether alice and bob have can have
memory or not
um okay um note this
inequalities relation between this this
all different variants of the model
so it is not very very difficult to see
that this inequality set of inequalities
hold for all
all functions and in fact all these
inequalities are actually exponentially
weaker
so in the sense that there exists a
function explicit functions for which
this model is the complexity in this
model is exponentially better than this
one
and similarly there exists a function
for which this is exponentially better
than u1 and similarly here
okay so uh so so a quick recap like we
have these two players alice and bob
and instead of having standard
communication complexity we can have
we can choose to have whether they have
memory or not
and whether the communication is two-way
versus one-way and we can have
all this different variants of
communication complexity model
now we would like to see how it fits
with
other space bounded model that have been
already already studied
so here i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
describe three different
space bounded models um
and then we will see how they are
connected to our newly defined model
so first of all it's a garden hose model
it was introduced by burman
burman and others in 2013 and
this is really a playful definition of a
communication complexity model where
alice and bob they have
their input x and y
but they are actually neighbors and they
share a few pipes which are going
going across the boundary of their of
their gardens
and based on their private inputs alice
makes
alice also has they also have some of
the hoses so so
alice makes some of the connections
alice put some of the
matches some of the openings on her side
bob also matches
uh some of the openings on his side and
they cannot see their connections um
uh on on so they can only see their
connections on on their respective side
and alice also connects the tab to the
to one of the pipes based on her input
now obviously if uh since it's a
matching of the pipes
and if if alice starts a flow
then water would eventually go back and
forth through these pipes based on the
connections
and it will eventually spill on one side
and in this case we are seeing that it
it actually spills on both sides so we
can we can define that
if water ever spills on bob's side the
function value would be one
uh if it spills on alice's side the
function value would be zero
then we can say that if this this this
way we can compute a function and it
turns out that we can compute any
functions using using such setting
and the the um the complexity is
basically how many pipes we need
uh in order to compute a function f for
all possible x and y
and and the number of pi the pipes is
basically the complexity in this model
uh second space bounded variance that uh
that we know of
is uh was defined by brady adele in 2013
um so this this in this model
alice and bob they are limited memory
wise in the sense that
they don't have unlimited memory but
rather they have sn
amount of memory so both players have sn
amount of memory so it's
similar to our model here they don't
have any clock to remember like when
which round they are in if they want to
remember in which round they're in they
need to store it in this
in the space and again
here they send um
bits back and forth so instead of just
so unlike our model where where
the players exchange a message register
here this sends bix bits back and forth
and they just update their their private
private s and bits register and the
computer function in this way
and cost of computing a function is
basically the size of
such such register
um and then the third variant is
uh overlay communication complexity uh
so this was
uh so i've i've already mentioned that
this was
uh this was introduced in 2014 by by
papa constantine denu
and um this is exactly a setting where
uh alice has unlimited amount of memory
but bob doesn't have any
any memory at all so bob doesn't know in
which round bob doesn't even know in
which round he's in
uh bob just receives a message so so now
the message
could be a multi-string message
at any round and bob receives a message
and bob can either
output 0 or 1 or he can continue
and and the goal is to compute a
function this way and
they have shown that this model is
characterized by this really beautiful
combinatorial
object called overlay so instead of so
in normal communication complexity we
have
a rectangle which gets partitioned into
smaller rectangles but
here it is it is it is a array of
rectangles
an overlay of rectangles and uh the the
main rectangle
gets covered by this array of rectangles
and any particular
point x and y gets the value of the
first rectangle that it encounters
okay so so having explained these three
things uh to three different models
uh let me tell you like how uh they are
related
to to our setting so as i mentioned i
mean this is this is exactly the setting
uh so this is exactly uh turns out to be
one of the setting that that we we
consider but
uh so we don't claim it to to do it
ourselves because this is already done
done in this in this work it just turns
out that when we set
like uh our models this way
in this this particular setting it turns
out to be the
exactly the overlay communication
complexity but let us see
like what how space bounded com
model is related to our setting now
from these two pictures here this is the
space bounded model this is our model
you can already already see that these
two things are
almost the same because here the
exchange message and then the update
register here the exchange
they send the message register back and
forth so these two
actually and and it actually turns out
to be same
so it's not very hard to see that if we
define
uh complexity in this model to be sm of
f for computing any function then
memoryless communication complexity is
actually upper bounded by 2 times
sm of f plus 1 and sm of
f is also upper bounded by
memory less communication complexity
plus log of memory less communication
complexity so these two
modules are exactly like linearly
linearly related
now uh we want to connect it to
gardiner's model so uh but
there is a claim from body body
in 2013 that gardiner's complexity is
actually related to the space-bounded
communication complexity that they
defined in this
in this manner so using this and the
relation that we have in the previous
slide it already immediately follows
that
gardiner's complexity and our defined
model of memoryless communication
complexity
is factor three related
but it turns out that we can actually uh
tighten this bound
and we can show that uh
non um memoryless communication
complexity
is actually similar to log of
gardener's complexity so it's actually
lower bounded by log of guardian's
complexity minus four
and upper bounded by log of gardiner's
complexity
so in other word uh these two models are
exactly
exactly the same
now one one advantage of having um
uh this this model the the memoryless
communication complexity is that
now we can look at all the gardeners
protocol uh or for instance the
space-bounded uh model
in terms of um non-deterministic in
terms of memoryless communication
complexity
and and study it there um
so so this is one of the consequences of
this tight relation that we have
obtained
which is about indirect storage access
now
indirect storage access function which
is defined this way it is it is
essentially
x of y of z so uh we are given this
indirect storage access functions where
it is a n bit string to
one bit string function but the function
is defined this way
this this input is interpreted as uh as
this so we have
a vector x we also have bunch of vectors
y's y i's
and we also have z and the way to
evaluate this function is
first of all z the integer value of z
points to one of the location of
y and that particular
y that we obtain that points to one of
the location of x
and then we look at that particular
location and look we look at whether
it's 0 or 1 and that's
essentially the output so that's why
it's like it's it's called indirect
storage axis and in order to turn it
into a distributed problem
we can give alice x and z and we can
give all the y's to bob
and you can see that this is this is
hard for a for a single player to
compute the
values they need to communicate and this
this
y is do not have to be unique so in so
because of that
it seems like in order to compute this
function in the garden hose model
um it it it it requires
omega n square many pipes and
and and that's why it was it was
conjectured by clock and sp in 2014 that
indirect storage axis function actually
requires omega n square
but using this new characterization i
mean new connection
that we have obtained via this
memoryless communication complexity
we can see that this conjecture is false
and we can actually get a protocol which
is linear in
n and this turns out to be very easy
protocol because
in the in the memoryless protocol it is
very easy because
alice just can send z to bob
and then bob can just compute y of y of
z and send it send it back to alice
and then finally alice can compute the
answer so
here the way the function is this is
defined
uh this y's could be at most login bits
and that's why the complexities is login
and since it is login if we translate it
back to the gardeners
model we get a protocol which is 16
times so this is linear so as we are
seeing that this is already a nobility
of this model that
we can
use this new um framework to study
um guardian's model uh we we can also
um show that so here i'm not mentioning
it
in this slide but we can also say
something non-trivial about
space-bounded model there we can say
that um
some of the things which which looks um
easy in
uh in space bounded model it actually
in using this framework we can actually
see that that's that's actually hard so
so
it makes this model makes things clear
to see
okay so so far we have this uh we have
established this following
uh inequality relating all this all this
different models so now we see that okay
these three
models are are actually equal
and this sits in between this this this
models
now see one one another advantage is
that
uh since log of gardeners is upper
bounded by
m one way of f meaning we can use
overlay complexity
to design a protocol for gardeners so
that gives us another way for designing
a protocol for guardians as well
and we have explored this direction and
that also turns out to be fruitful
and um uh so
so it happens that for this problem
disjointness with quadratic universe
it was conjectured to have again like
quadratic uh complexity in
uh like like omega and m square
complexity in
gardiner's model but using a protocol in
this model
we we see that we can actually slightly
reduce it to m square over log squared
so um so so so perhaps we can say that
the memoryless communication complexity
uh framework and its its variants um
are our cl cleaner framework for
studying
all these three previous space-bounded
communication complexity models
now um so so here
um i have already mentioned that the for
the overlay complexity there is this
really nice characterization
of of of overlay complexity so then the
question is can we also do the same
for memoryless communication complexity
can we come up with a characterization
like what is happening in terms of
partition when we talk about memory less
communication complexity
and it turns out that memoryless
communication complexity
is actually characterized by bipartite
branching programs so that's also
another
connection with another complexity
theory theoretic model which is
a branching program so before i explain
what is a bipartite branching program
let me let me
uh quickly tell you like what is a by
what is a branching program
so branching programs have um a
starting node and two sync nodes labeled
with zero and one and sync nodes do not
have an
any any out degree and
the starting node doesn't have any in
degree and every other node and
has including the including this node
has out degree 2 at most out degree 2
and they are labeled by variables of the
form x
i now the way it works is that
whenever we get a get an input x uh from
like x 0 to x
x n minus 1 that sets one of
that sets um that activates one of the
paths
and deactivate the other one and based
on that for any particular x
starting from the starting node we can
traverse the graph
and then reach either the zero node or
the one node
and then we say that a branching program
computes a function
f if for all the one input
starting from the starting node we reach
the one node
and for the zero inputs we reach the
zero node
and then the complexity of a branching
program is denoted to be the
smallest such branching program
computing uh f for all possible x
now we can also have bipartite branching
program now in bipartite branching
program it is it is exactly the same
scenario but now all the nodes instead
of getting denoted by
all the variables x i's now they are
either denoted by
a function f i coming from this function
family
curly curly f or denoted by
g gj coming from this function family g
now what is happening here is that at
each node we can compute any function
based on either x or either y but not
not both and again the out degree is two
so again the goal is the same like
starting from the starting node we want
to reach either zero
or one so this branching program since
it's bipartite
in nature it is capable of computing a
bipartite function which is like
f of x and y and it outputs a boolean
value
we can also have a generalized version
of bipartite branching program so
here the difference is from the
brypatite branching program is that
it is this exactly the same scenario but
now instead of having degree two
here we can have more than degree two in
fact we can have up to k
for for some fixed k and
uh so so that's why it's it's a
generalized version of the bipartite
branching program all the other other
parameters remain
remain same now uh
it it actually turns out that uh
bipartite
uh generalized bipartite branching
programs can be simulated by a bipartite
it can be turned
into a bipartite branching program just
by increasing
um increasing the size by by a quadratic
factor
and then we could actually show that
this generalized function of bipartite
branching program
characterizes memoryless communication
complexity and
the way it works is we can look at uh
every message of the memoryless
communication complexity that the
players send
and in a sense it acts as a as uh
as a node in the generalized bipartite
branching program so so using this this
fact
uh we can say that non um we can we can
say that
memoryless communication complexity is
actually characterized by bipartite
branching program
okay um uh finally um
let me say another connection which is
uh
of of this newly defined memoryless
communication complexity
with with formula size so it was already
known
uh from the work of clock and sp from
2014 that
any formula of size s containing
arbitrary fan in two gates
can be converted into a gardiner's
protocol of almost the same size so of
of size
s to s to the one plus epsilon for for
any arbitrary epsilon
now in this work we are showing that any
arbitrary guardian host formulas
can be simulated by a memoryless
protocol without any loss in the in the
sense that
if we start with the s size guardianos
protocol
then we get a longest size memoryless
protocol so s
becomes log is here so using these two
results we can say that given any
formula
um of arbitrary fan into of size s
can be converted into a memoryless
protocol of size one plus epsilon log s
now in the contra positive direction
this says that this new model of
memoryless communication complexity
actually gives us a way
of proving formula size lower want
because
um so so any any lower bound in this
model would actually translate to the
formula size lower bound so in in in
in its nature this is similar to the
result of um customers and meters and
uh so here in we have we have this
form of um communication complexity
where just by analyzing communication
complexity we can actually
show a lower bond for for formula size
okay um but i should highlight here that
in this model uh in this in the
memoryless model
constants really matter in the sense
that um
here a login and two login shouldn't be
treated as
as equal because uh a login bound in the
in the non
in the in the memory list model would
actually translate to n uh
lower bound in the um in the formula
size whereas two log n would actually
translate to n square lower bound so
constants really
really matter here okay
and at last i want to mention that
we also defined a quantum version of
all the variants of memoryless
communication complexity model
and we managed to show that uh
the quantum versions are actually
exponentially better than the
um are better than their classical
uh counterpart first for explicit
function so we could find different
functions for which
this inequalities are exponentially
weaker except this one so we couldn't
couldn't do it for the
for the memoryless model
for the other variants we could find it
okay finally let me stop with uh with
with one main open question
so i have already said this in a sense
uh
so note that uh
we know that if we if we have so we we
made this connection
from memory less communication
complexity to gardeners to branching
programs
to formula sizes and we we also see that
proving a lower bound here would
actually give a lower bound in
all these different models so what we
could do is
we could prove a lower bound for c equal
to one so in this model we could we
could prove a lower bound of
log n but we couldn't prove any lower
bound yet
which is uh greater than equal to one so
we
sorry which is greater than one strictly
greater than one
and in particular a such bound or
greater than one
would actually have consequences uh in
or first of all in gardiner's model
because if we if we could prove
c strictly greater than one um then
that would that would prove a super
linear lower bond for guardians which is
which is
actually open and this would also give
a lower bond for bipartite branching
programs
so if we if we could prove like c for
any c
the c log n bound that we proved we
would actually give n to the c
lower bound for the bipartite branching
program and this is this is similar in
flavor of
tal's recent work on
bipartite formula size lower bonds so
here we are getting bipartite
branching programs lower bond
and also note that if we manage to prove
c to be greater than 2 plus epsilon so
that
then that would be uh that would have a
really nice consequence of
having omega n to the 2 plus epsilon
lower bound for the general formula size
and which is actually open from
uh with the blessed we know from uh
from natchez baruch from 1966.
and um one possible candidate that
that we think is viable is this three
click
click problem here alice and bob are
given two strings x and y
and if we take x x or y so then
this xor string would actually represent
a graph
and then the question is whether this
graph um
an n vertex graph and then the question
is whether this graph
would contains a triangle or not and um
it it seems like for this problem
uh we um it's actually it cannot be done
with
with login in memory less communication
complexity
okay so with that i'll stop here uh
thank you for
listening and you can you can visit uh
this link for the full version of this
paper
thank you